hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight on HBO although here I'm on
YouTube like I'm about to give the least
anticipated makeup tutorial of all time
I'm sorry but now is not the time that I
share my patented contouring technique
which I call John Turing it's about it's
about blending it's about blends it's
about blending the makeup is what I
think it is about now we're off for a
few weeks and in the meantime I thought
I would do one of our periodic reviews
of this shows fan mail now of course no
one sent me actual mail because I'm not
currently fighting in the Revolutionary
War or as they call it where I'm from
the war of well we've still got Canada
we've still got Canada so now as as
always our fan mail comes in the form of
YouTube comments the most cogent written
argument for never learning how to read
I would like to share some of my
favorite comments not all of which are
hateful in fact one viewer even wrote
John Oliver has magnificent eyebrows
which which I appreciate it and I'll
tell you why because no one has ever
called any part of my body
magnificent ever but then then I've got
a little confused when I saw that
someone else had written John Oliver's
eyebrows are alien caterpillars and move
independently of each other and I
thought well that's okay that's okay
that does still technically fall under
the umbrella of magnificent
there's no more magnificent eyebrow than
one that is sentient and moves
independently so you know what sorry
Cara Delevingne I'm the new queen of
eyebrow sickness step off
step off Cara the problem is things went
steadily downhill from there one one
commenter said John Oliver looks like a
mix of a Pokemon and a child molester
which made me a little mad because there
is already a mix between a Pokemon and a
child molester and it's called Gengar
look at that creep look at that creep
but the most discouraging thing I saw
was a comment that read at least you
serve your corporate masters well
unfunny live-action beaker which which
was incredibly discouraging because
mainly because I was annoyed that I
hadn't thought of that myself I don't
mind being insulted by commenters but I
really it really hurts when I'm out
comedians by them honestly many people
who try to insult me on YouTube have
badly missed the mark
for example someone wrote he's aged so
much which is just not an insult it's
merely an affirmation I've continued to
succeed of my number one life goal not
not dying in a significant way as
something I've been consistently good at
since I was born
another another comment simply described
our show as uniquely boring which again
it's line insult it's not for something
to be both unique and boring is a true
feat it's a phrase that I would reserve
for something exceptional like a Ken
Burns documentary about snails but of
all the comments I read one stood out
above all the others and really made me
feel good about my career choices and
that comment laid out a challenge a
challenge I'm prepared to take on
because this comment read John Oliver I
bet you one zillion dollars that you
won't feature this comment in a video
well Touche I'm not
and to the rest of you I will see you
never I don't need this anymore
I'm a zillionaire now last week tonight
returns on the 24th of July unless I
can't find a place to dock my new yacht
until then you're all monsters goodbye